bonjour bienvenue sur rt france alors
manifestement pas de sommet en bruxelles
moscou 2 prévu pour le moment on est
d'accord ce n'est pas figé dans le
marbre
on sait que c'est sur la table parler
d'un sommet qui ne va pas avoir lieu
c'est déjà en parler on peut le voir
ainsi
je pense que c'est une occasion ratée je
pense que l'initiative franco-allemande
de la combe de merkel et qui lui dit
fier elle était justifiée parce que
s'inscrit dans un mouvement plus utile
car alisme qui reprend ses droits
on a vu que joe biden a rencontré le
président poutine en suisse genève la
semaine dernière
ça ne veut pas dire qu'on est d'accord
loin de là et je pense que l'union
européenne telle était la volonté de
madame merkel et de monsieur macro
n'allez pas rencontrer liant la nuit
africaine pour lui raconter de belles
histoires pour contraire je pense que la
volonté et deux chefs d'état de
gouvernement était de mettre les points
sur les i et de rappeler un certain
nombre d'obligations auxquels la russie
doit se soustraire notamment en matière
de droits de l'homme
à l'exemple de ce qui se passe en
biélorussie nous sommes d'accord on vous
le disions ce sera pas un sommet pour
nouer un partenariat mais pour dialoguer
ceux qui ne veulent pas de ce dialogue
quelle est leur stratégie parce que la
communication on sait c'est parfois la
meilleure façon de désamorcer une
dispute je pense qu'il y a
historiquement de très très grande
différence entre des pays de ce qu'on
appelait l'explosion éthiques
il a il faut rappeler un principe très
simple de l'union européenne quel
principe de l'unanimité et il n'y a pas
eu le principe de l'unanimité qui a pu
se mettre en oeuvre pour enclencher ce
sommet c'est à dire qu'un certain nombre
de pays ont refusé que l'union
européenne s'associer à ce processus et
furent uniquement l'union européenne
n'avait pas d'autre choix que de
mettre fin à ce processus mais le fait
même que les deux grands pays l'union
européenne à savoir la république
fédérale d'allemagne et la france lance
un tel message
c'est déjà un signe très fort c'est à
dire c'est aussi vouloir que l'union
européenne joue un rôle comme global
play en dire en anglais
en politique étrangère il ne pas laisser
à la russie aux états unis dans ce cas
là non mais la chine le monopole des
relations internationales la france par
mc ren l'allemagne par merkel voulaient
tout simplement déclaré nous sommes nous
l'union européenne
la principale puissance économique au
monde laissez-nous être aussi une idée
très grande puissance politique au monde
et cela n'a pas été compris par un
certain nombre de pays de l'union
européenne alors la dîmière poutine joe
biden à un sommet a déjà eu lieu en gala
merkel en a parlé en tout à l'heure
selon elle et je vais la cité le
président des états unis a rencontré
vladimir poutine pour un entretien
sérieux sans que cela donne l'impression
que ce soit une récompense pour le
président russe on va faire entre les
lignes est ce que l'europe finalement a
peur je dirais familièrement qu'on lui
vole la place que les états unis d'où
grille la priorité non elle voudrait
avoir sa place
cesserait problème mais ne l'a pas et je
trouve que la déclaration de mme merkel
est totalement justifiée c'était de dire
clairement si nous voulons montrer
monsieur poutine
c'est pour lui parler clairement
ouvertement lui dire ce qu'est l'union
européenne
quelles sont les valeurs qui sont liées
à l'union européenne et que étant donné
que la russie est un grand partenaire
il faut aussi rappeler à la russie que
les valeurs de l'union européenne
constitue un socle pour lequel on auquel
on reste fidèles et où on ne transige
pas et c'était ça l'important c'est à
dire affirmé une puissance européenne
puissance de politique étrangère
européenne
madeleine l'a très bien compris
macron l'a très bien compris merkel a
très bien compris mais l'union
européenne où certains pays de l'union
européenne ne l'ont pas compris voilà la
différence c'est à dire il n'y a aucune
allégeance par rapport au régime de
moscou
mais il y a la nécessité pour l'union
européenne a de s'affirmer comme une
puissance de petite angèle b pour
reconnaître à la russie sans poids
mondial qui quel que soit le mouvement
et en suivant à prendre en compte et ça
personne ne le remettrait en compte
parce que l'europe ne peut pas se passer
de la russie et vice versa c'est ça le
noeud du problème
exactement il serait pourquoi favorable
pour tout le monde que la russie et
l'europe ait de meilleures relations
ça fait longtemps on dira je parle un
peu comme un grand père que je ne tue
pas d'ailleurs mais rappelons nous
souvenons nous des très bonnes relations
de l'union soviétique entre gambade
chauffe et l'union où la communauté
européenne de l'époque cela a permis de
très grandes avancées
cela a permis en partie la chute du mur
de berlin
donc vous savez c'est très facile d'être
contre mais de temps en temps il faut
être con pour être pour cette
conversation c'est aussi ouvrir de
nouvelles perspectives pour une europe
stable et pacifique et juste et plus
démocratique
elle est maire aka sa sauce merci
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes professeur
d'études européennes merci à vous
d'avoir été en direct sur arte france